i get to come in and i get to be really
bad
luckily i had the amazing the incredible
anthony starr this is your entry i'm on
the other side
on my side the other way the other way
well that way to blow the intro
and and hello
oh my god hi my nana's your biggest fan
i'm stormfront great i'm so excited
because in the graphic novel stormfront
was a guy what was it like for you to
come into this gender flipped role
i think it's really fun i think they've
swapped the gender
intentionally not just because they
needed another lady i think they've
thought a lot about like
how to tell this story best for this
time and
that a woman would be a really
interesting choice what are you talking
about
oh hi i'm in the seven
[Music]
oh god the reason we made stormfront
female was really for two reasons one is
we were really looking to again
create the worst possible nightmare for
homelander and the worst thing that
could happen to homelander
was a woman who wasn't scared of him and
was stealing his spotlight because he is
a big gaping hole of insecurity
ultimately and the idea that a woman
could be more popular than him
and not be scared of him is just so
unbearable to him so we did we did
that we wanted a character who
at first you sort of like but then as
the season goes on you reveal like oh
dear god there's
there's so many awful things about this
character
she's got a whole army of soups don't do
we need more soup and there's just so
many reasons why i would never be cast
in this role
and the fact that they let me do it is
just
incredible and i get to come in and i
get to be really bad
which is both fun sometimes and
sometimes really uncomfortable and hard
as a genius i mean she came in i think
our very first audition session
and i was like oh there there she is
she's so
smart but her comic timing is just so
incredible really the strength of her
intelligence and her wit
we need someone who's going to stand in
front of homelander and
intimidate him not the other way around
and she just had
that strength of character and humor
that
she could do it wonderful great
all right great
well i think this is going great
you